- What's up Believe Nation?
It's time for another update
on the path to one million
subscriber challenge that I'm on.
Basically I'm highlighting my journey
to get to one million subscribers,
and giving you some tips,
advice, and feedback,
along the way to help you
achieve whatever your YouTube goals are.
Last month when I did the video,
I had 639,000 subscribers.
I'm sitting now at 698.
30,000 swing?
No, 60,000 swing.
60,000 swing in a positive direction.
That's awesome.
Getting closer to hitting my million goal.
The past couple videos I've talked about
the importance of upload frequency.
I've talked about looking up people
like Eric Thomas and Gary Vaynerchuk.
People who are considered
to have immense talent.
People whose channels I love,
and they produce some amazing content,
and Eric wasn't producing enough content
to hit massive YouTube goals.
Gary now started to increase his frequency
and is going to pass me soon,
and so again this may
not be the only thing.
YouTube is not the only thing.
I understand these people
have other businesses
and it's great, I do too.
This series is focused only on
how to get subscribers for your channel.
We've talked a lot about upload frequency.
It's really important for YouTube.
It's part of their algorithm.
They want you to upload regularly.
Once a day is the new minimum.
I'm at three per day using my team.
There's a big growth that you'll get
from going once per week to once per day.
Another big jump from once
per day to two per day,
in terms of how much YouTube
will promote your stuff.
Between two and three, not as big a gap.
So it may not be worth
going to that extreme,
but I'm testing it out and
playing around with it.
I encourage you,
increase your upload
frequency, maintain quality,
and you'll see a dramatic
rise in your YouTube channel.
It doesn't mean that
you can't have success
uploading fewer videos,
but why drive on the side roads
when you can go on the highway?
I'm playing the YouTube's algorithm
and if you do it as well you'll be able
to beat people who have more skills,
who have more money, who have
more of a background in it,
because you understand
the algorithm better.
Today I want to focus on understanding
which series are working and which aren't,
and I'm going to model and
compare another YouTuber,
that we've had some fun with.
Grant Cardone, friend of a channel.
He's been on my channel
talking about his book.
We've done some videos on him.
A great guy to look at
if you're looking for
anything about entrepreneurship,
sales, motivation.
He's a good YouTuber to check out,
and so I'm going to
compare my channel to his,
and give his some recommendations
to increase his YouTube goals as well.
Let's pull up the data quickly.
You can see here I'm at 697,000 subs.
Grant's at 248.
What's interesting as we scroll down
you see that Grant's subs have been
pretty much consistent
around the 200 range per day
until recently where it really shot up,
and he's actually coming close to me,
and beating me on some days here.
Good job, Grant,
and one of the things I want to look at
dissecting his channel is,
are all the videos that he's
doing adding to the channel?
Helping him out with his growth?
Before jumping in on his,
I want to show you an example from mine.
The two things that I
really pay attention to
when I'm evaluating a
new series is watch time,
because watch time is the single
most important variable
that YouTube looks at.
If you are giving YouTube
watch time for their videos,
they will reward your
videos and rank you higher.
Every new series that I launch,
I look at the watch time,
and then I look at is it leading
to subscriber growth or not for me?
If my goal is to get to
a million subscribers,
that's the name of this series,
that's the next goal on my list,
then I need to make sure that
every series that I launch
leads to subscriber growth.
I'll usually give a series
three to four chances to see.
If it's helping me with
my subscriber growth,
then I keep it.
If it's not, I'll kill it,
unless it serves another purpose.
If I'm making a sales video.
If I'm showing my life.
If there's a strategic
reason behind a video,
besides subscriber growth then I keep it,
but if there isn't,
if I'm hoping to use this video
to help me grow my channel
and it doesn't lead to subscriber growth,
that's when we kill it.
Let's take a quick look at
two of the videos I did,
and then we'll jump into Grant's channel.
This is the first video
that I did on this series.
How to Get 1 Million YouTube Subscribers.
This video had 10 days watch time,
which isn't that great,
and only led to eight subscriptions.
That's not a fantastic start
for what a video would get on my channel,
but it's worth an extra
shot, an extra test.
The second one I did was
me and Gary Vaynerchuk.
That was the last one of the series.
This one had 40 days watch time,
and it drove 62 new
subscribers, which is better.
This is version three
right now in the series.
This one right here is version three
and we'll see how well it does.
This will help tell me am I
going to keep this series or not?
I highly encourage you to look at
for every video series that you launch,
whatever new ideas that you have,
give it three or four tests
to get some good data on,
and does it lead to watch time,
and does it lead to
subscribers for your channel?
If it does, keep it.
If it doesn't, kill it.
Let's jump in on Grant's channel,
and I can show you what he's doing.
This is Grant's channel,
and Grant is doing an
amazing job at the content.
It's really rare to find people
who are keeping up with me on the content.
I think actually recently
he's ahead of me.
This is two hours ago.
17 hours, 18 hours, 18
hours, 19 hours, 22 hours.
One thing I would say,
if you're going to post this much,
spread it out a little bit more.
If you're going to post
five, six videos in a day,
spread them out over a
couple hours each time,
so they're not back to back
because it gives a little more room
for the videos to breathe.
Here 22, 19, 18, 18, 17.
These are all going to be lumped together,
and all of these videos
could have had more views
if you spaced them out.
Like this one that was two hours ago,
one day, two day, and so on.
It's great to see Grant
uploading tons of content
and I consider Grant to
be an amazing speaker,
and has lots of great
wisdom and advice to share.
What's the deal?
He's uploading tons of content,
but is stuck at 250,000 subs.
Let's break down some of the series,
so we can look at where he's doing right,
and what he's doing wrong.
This is a typical Grant video.
The news ones coming out at least.
46 days watch time.
That's awesome.
18 subscriptions driven.
Here's another one.
150 days watch time.
13 subscriptions driven.
27 days watch time, 12
subscriptions driven.
He's driving between 10 to 20 subscribers
per new video that he puts out.
That's about Grant.
This is all Grant just talking,
ranting into his phone.
It doesn't have to be a setup.
He's just going off the cuff,
and Grant is one of
the best at doing this.
Going off the cuff, being live,
sharing his opinions and
rolling with the punches.
A typical Grant video
where he's just doing that,
leads to 10 to 20 subs, which is great.
Next time I'll look at some of his series.
This is a series that he
has called Ask the Pro.
Grant is not actually
in these videos here,
and look at the difference on the videos.
Five days watch time,
zero subscriptions driven.
The other really important thing
to understand about the YouTube algorithm,
and this is worth a
pause on this point here.
If you have a video that
underperforms your average,
if you have a video that does
really poorly on your channel,
it actually hurts your future video.
This was an important lesson I learned.
I was just putting up tons of content.
Content after content.
Figure let YouTube pick
what's going to work.
It's adding value to the audience.
I don't care if a video only
gets 1,000 views or 3,000 views.
Doesn't really make a difference.
It's just still high quality content.
If a video does not do well,
especially considering what
your average video will do,
then that video hurts the future videos
that come out on your channel.
The flip side is, if a
video does really well,
if it takes off,
then that video will help your
future videos on your channel.
You always want to be producing content
that is better than the average.
It keeps raising the bar on
watch time for the channel
but this is really important,
because if you have a series
that is at zero subscribers growth,
and it's underperforming
compared to your average,
then whatever future
video that Grant puts out,
that may be him ranting,
even though those typically overperform,
YouTube will not rank it as well,
because this Ask the
Pro video underperforms.
That's where it's really
really really important
to pay attention to the series
that are working or not,
and the ones that aren't kill them,
because they hurt all your future videos.
Let's jump back in and
look at this stream again.
This is Ask the Pro,
and maybe it's because
Grant's not in this show,
that it doesn't do as well.
This often happens with
personality driven channels
when it's under somebody's name
and then somebody comes on
and Grant's not there,
the video won't do as well.
This video had zero subscribers growth.
Here's another one, Ask the Pro.
Same guy, has another guest coming on.
11 days watch, negative
one subscriptions driven.
He actually lost subscribers
because of this video.
He lost a subscriber.
Instead of it growing,
he's losing base because of this.
Maybe there are other Ask the Pro videos.
I haven't gone too far back in the series.
Maybe I happened to pick
two that underperformed,
but in general if a video series
is leading to negative growth,
and is not doing well compared
to your usual videos on time watched,
then it's time to kill that series
and move on to something else,
unless it serves a strategic purpose
to help in your main business.
How you make money, how
you add value, grow.
Next I want to jump in on
some of Grant's shorter clips.
What he'll often do here is,
you'll have a main big video like this.
This is one of Grant's
videos, Cardone Zone,
talking about saving for retirement.
72 days watched, seven
subscriptions driven.
It's okay.
It's actually interesting
how his set pieces like this
underperform his live stuff,
because this takes a lot of time.
There's setup time, there's
crew time, there's questions.
there's a lot of effort that
goes into making one of these videos,
for it to only have seven
subscriptions driven,
compared to something like this that's 18.
This is 13.
This took Grant 10 minutes.
He's sitting there on his phone.
He gets 157 days watch
time and 13 subs driven
compared to this where there's
a lot more team and effort involved.
Finding ways for Grant to
be more off the cuff, live,
exciting, doing crazy things,
I think would really help this channel,
but what I really want
to get into here was,
he has this clip that
comes up on May 21st,
and he has this clip which
comes up also on May 21st
which is just a short version of
something that he says
in the original video.
This video is 38 minutes long.
This video is one minute long.
Look at this.
Look at the difference.
72 days watched, two days watched.
Seven subs driven, two subs driven.
This video again is underperforming,
what's on his channel.
YouTube doesn't like this video.
They're going to down rank it.
They're not going to send it out.
It's not going to get a lot
of attention, attraction, awareness.
It's not going to show up a lot
on the recommended down here on the side,
and now the future video
that Grant puts out
right after this is going to take a hit.
If you produce a video
that is below your average,
your next video takes a hit.
It's super important to understand.
He does it again here.
Here he's doing affiliate marketing,
and Grant Cardone coaching.
Awesome.
52 days watch time, amazing.
23 subscriptions driven, great.
It's leading to new subs finding him.
He puts out a one minute version of it.
Again, let's check the dates.
May 21st, again May 21st, same thing.
Now spacing it out may help a little bit,
because if people just saw this,
they're not going to
want to watch this again.
They're not going to be moved by it,
because they just heard the same points.
Spacing them out can really help,
but still I'd be inclined
to kill this series.
Look at this.
46 hours of watch time.
52 days of watch time,
compared to 46 hours of watch time.
YouTube hates this video,
will not promote it,
will not give it more exposure,
and then again, whatever
video Grant puts out next
is going to take a hit,
because he put this video up.
But there are four subs, so it's okay,
but this is the one to pay attention to,
and this one minute series should,
I would test it putting it later on.
Instead of putting it the same day,
put it next week.
Where people who may not have seen
the original video can see this short bit,
or just test to see if it's working,
because maybe that short one minute clip
should only be on Instagram
or only on Facebook,
and not on YouTube,
because I don't want you taking a hit.
Here's another quick example.
36 hours of watch time and
one subscription driven
for a 1:32 video.
This is something that his team
should be paying attention to,
and saying stop making these videos.
Save them for social, the other channels,
and put up the better stuff on YouTube.
The next thing we want to do
is go series by series,
and pay attention to what he's putting up,
and you do this on your channel.
Look at every series that you have.
It's harder when you're looking at it
from an outsider's perspective.
If I had access to Grant's analytics,
I could provide a much
more in depth report,
because you can create
groups a lot more easily,
but go series by series.
Here's one.
Confessions of an Entrepreneur
with Grant Cardone.
He's having a guest come on.
67 days watch time, great.
Drove 11 subs.
That's about average with his
Grant Rant series with his phone.
Again, is it worth this,
spending the time to book this person
to do all the work, to drive with them.
Maybe he gets a lot of pride with it.
Maybe he loves it.
Maybe that's where he gets his mojo from.
That may be a series worth continuing,
but again, compared to
something like this,
or something like this,
where he's just sitting
there with his phone,
it gets way better results,
which is something to think about
when you're comparing how much
time it takes to make a video.
Here's another series.
91 days watch time on Young Hustlers.
Eight subs driven.
Decent watch time.
Okay for subs.
Again, I don't know how
much Grant is in here.
He joins later on.
This is another one
that I would look at like
watch time is decent on this one.
Subs are below average, what
Grant should be getting.
I'd go back and look at
every Young Hustlers episode,
and do an analysis of is
this series worth keeping?
What topics will he hit.
What topics didn't.
They make the Young
Hustlers series even better.
Here's another one.
Cardone Mastermind Event Live at 2:00.
This is a half an hour Mastermind call
with somebody, not Grant.
It's half an hour of this
guy answering questions.
10 days watch time, not that great.
Negative two subs.
He lost subscribers because of this video,
and again the next video Grant puts up
is going to take a hit,
because this video underperformed.
Next I want to talk about some
of his more high profile guests,
and this is where Grant has really
started to excel recently.
If I go back to his Social Blade account,
you can see that he has
recently really taken off.
A lot of that is because of the guests
that he's had on board.
This is a video where he
brought on Gary Vaynerchuk.
It's relatively new.
476 days of watch time and
180 subscriptions driven.
This is still a new video.
It's still going to do well.
It's still going to
continue to drive traffic
and awareness for him.
They mention in this video that
he spent a lot of time trying
to get Gary V. to come on board
and recruiting him and back and forth.
It was worth it.
Grant does a really
good job in interviews.
He's really good in the live setting here.
The next one he did here, Tai Lopez.
This is one of my favorite Tai
Lopez interviews of all time
and Grant did a really good job.
I really appreciated the hustle
and the drive and the questions here.
Look at this.
Two years of watch time.
One of his best videos of
recent memory at least,
two years of watch time and
233 subscriptions driven.
This series Power Players is working.
When he brings on high profile guests
and you allow Grant to be Grant
and share his wisdom, ask
the questions, be real, raw,
and the things that Grant does, it works.
It helps generate a lot of
traffic, attention, awareness.
This video goes up.
YouTube is going to love
whatever next video he puts up
and give him extra awareness.
I would definitely go hard
on the Power Player series,
and bring on more guests
to let Grant be Grant,
interview and involve the audience.
Next, let's jump to the G&E Show.
I'm just basically doing this through
all the series that I could find,
just quickly looking at his channel
and the video uploads.
How To Give Back, The G&E Show.
39 days watched, okay.
Two subscriptions driven.
Not great on the subscriptions driven.
There's another example here.
The G&E Show, The Business of Marriage.
39 days watched.
Negative two subscriptions driven.
He's losing subscribers
because of this show,
and again it's going to hurt
him for the future videos.
Where this helps is it's long.
He gets to watch time,
because it's a 48 minute episode,
compared to the other
stuff which is shorter.
This is going to help
him with the watch time,
but hurt him on the subs.
Again, I would go back and
look at every G&E Show,
just like the Young Hustlers and say,
I'm getting decent watch time on it,
but I'm not getting the subs
that I should be getting
compared to my other videos.
What's wrong?
Do we cancel the show?
Do we find what episodes
are pulling really well
and go more in on that?
Again, maybe some of these
shows have a strategic purpose,
so that it's outside of just
generating subs for his channel.
Maybe he really loves
working with his wife.
working with his associate
on the Young Hustlers show.
Maybe there's other reasons
beyond just subscriber growth,
but paying attention to it is important.
The next thing I want to
highlight are the sales videos,
and this is something
that will often come up.
We want to use our YouTube channel
as an opportunity to sell stuff,
to grow, to promote stuff,
and so Grant was promoting
the 10X Growth Con
and had all these people
talking about how great it was,
and again, only four hours watched.
This might be one of the worst videos
of recent memory on Grant's channel.
He lost a subscriber because of it.
Only had four hours watch time,
and he had a bunch of these.
If you go to his channel around
the time of this conference,
there is maybe 15 of
these different videos
of people talking about how great
the 10X Growth Con was,
and that hurt his channel,
but there's a reason for it.
He's trying to promote his conference.
The 10X Growth Con,
and it's okay to use your channel
to promote something that
helps your business objectives.
Yes, he's knowingly taking
a hit on his YouTube growth,
losing a subscriber because of this one,
hurting his future videos
because of the poor watch time,
but it's helping him generate sales,
and awareness and attention
for his Growth Conference.
It's okay to have some
videos that hurt the channel,
if it leads to another strategically
important decision for your company.
Here's another quick one.
Again, negative one.
He lost a subscriber because of it.
Only 10 hours watch time.
This whole series of videos
is going to hurt the channel.
Now if you put up some great
quality content afterwards,
you'll start to raise the average,
so that they get more
promotion awareness as well,
but I love getting a momentum
of positive video growth.
The last thing I want to talk about
is Grant's live stuff.
This is a recent one that Grant did.
Grant Interviews a Job
Candidate: Live Footage.
141 days watch time, 32 subs driven.
This is a good video,
and it's just Grant sitting there
talking to a guy whose
doing a job interview.
The camera is shaky.
It's handheld.
There's not a lot of production quality
and thinking that went into it.
It's just Grant doing his thing,
which Grant is amazing at.
If we go back to another
video on his channel,
this is a recent one, also from May.
86,000 views, 511 days of watch time,
and 221 subs driven.
Again, this is just a guy and a tripod,
are just holding a camera,
seeing Grant do his thing live.
If I go back, this is from May 21st.
Let's find some other May 21st videos.
This one, which did well.
This is Grant ranting with
just him and a camera.
May 21st also, but only
13 subscriptions driven.
May 21st, this one was May 21st.
Zero subs, only five days.
May 21st, minus one subs, 11 days.
Fast forward.
May 21st, 39 days, two
subs for the G&E Show.
May 19th, four hours, minus one subs.
The Growth Con we looked at,
and then here 32 subs driven.
141 days of watch time on May 21st,
just following Grant around.
511 days, 221 subs driven.
Same day, May 21st.
Just following Grant around.
Grant should, if his only goal was,
I want to get watch time,
I want to get views,
I want to drive my YouTube
channel to the moon,
then he should just do a vlog
and have people follow him around
and watch him do his stuff live,
because that's what he is amazing at.
If we go to his channel
and look at all the videos that he has,
the most popular video
of all time that he has,
is this, doing an actual live
sales call, sales training.
Four years ago.
1.4 million views.
Let's check out the stats on this video.
Look at this.
It drove 8,339 subscribers to his channel.
This is the kind of stuff that
Grant needs to do more of.
If I was in charge of Grant's channel,
if I was in charge of advising him
on his YouTube strategy,
that's what I would focus on.
I'd say less set pieces.
I'd say less short one minute clips,
immediately after a full length clip.
I'd say go in harder on the videos
where you can bring on guests,
and have a great time with them,
and do more live stuff
of following you around.
Not the setup, not the
official camera crew.
You, live people following me around,
doing something that Grant Cardone does.
I think that's where you're going to get
the highest leverage from your channel.
That's my quick take on
Grant Cardone's channel.
I'm a big fan of the hustle
and the upload frequency.
He's doing a great job on that,
and is set for his channel to explode
is he makes a couple minor tweaks
that will really help him.
Let me give into some questions
that you guys had from last month's video,
and see what you have that I
can maybe help you out with.
First up, dudewat212.
There is no guarantee that YouTube
will exist 60 years from
now, let alone forever.
Who cares about 60 years from now?
How old am I?
I just turned 37.
I'm going to be 97 in 60 years.
Who cares what's happening in 60 years?
I care about what's happening right now.
That's what it's all about.
I'm not addicted to YouTube.
I want help a billion entrepreneurs,
and wherever the entrepreneurs are,
that's where I want to be.
I never wanted to be YouTube famous.
My initial goal starting this
wasn't to have a million subscribers.
It's to help a billion entrepreneurs.
However that happens.
If YouTube, in two years,
isn't as popular anymore,
and everybody's moving
to Instagram or Snapchat,
or whatever the newest thing
is that everybody's on,
then that's where I'm going to be,
and that's where you should be too.
Don't hold on to the
platforms like MySpace
and all the other ones that go under.
You could have made a
serious amount of money,
had a serious amount of
impact on MySpace in the day,
but if you stick there,
then you're not going to be successful.
You have to be where the attention is.
If your customers are there,
where your audience is, you need to be.
That's Marketing 101.
Be where your customers are.
Right now, that's YouTube.
This video will help people
who are trying to get
whatever their YouTube goal is,
your subscription goals are,
pay attention to the
series, upload frequently,
do the data to understand that
this series is working and this one isn't,
and you'll have success.
Next, star light.
Create one million Google accounts.
Subscribe to your desired
channel and ta da.
That is a way to get YouTube subscribers,
to get to a million.
You can also buy them if you want.
This is talking about legit ways
to get to one million subscribers.
I don't buy my subs.
Next, Ryan.
Watch out for Valuetainment.
He has quality content.
I'm a fan.
I'm a fan of Patrick Bet-David.
He's got some great
content for entrepreneurs.
Maybe I'll do a breakdown of
his channel at some point.
Patrick's been on my channel.
I've been on his.
It's a great collaboration,
and I'm supporting anybody who wants
to help entrepreneurs.
I don't think there's
enough quality people
who are trying to help
entrepreneurs on YouTube,
so it's been amazing to see
the work that Patrick's put out
and I would love for him to
hit a million subs as well.
It means that entrepreneurs
are being helped.
Next, RCSparks Studio.
YouTube is going to pummel you guys,
because your views are small.
You're taking lots of YouTube
real estate producing no views.
Subs mean nothing to YouTube
if they're not watching your films.
Watch time bro, watch time.
Yes, I agree dude.
That's why we're talking about watch time.
It's not just about subs,
but it is definitely not about views.
Don't pay attention to views at all.
You're looking at the wrong metric, dude.
I generate 42 million minutes
in watch time per month,
which for a channel of my size sub wise,
that's really good.
I'm hitting above my belt.
Views don't matter, watch time does.
This entire series of how do we break down
what a good series looks like?
It's watch time and subs driven.
That's how I analyze if
a series is good or not,
and that's how you should too.
OnePercentBetter.
I suspect Valuetainment will
be catching you guys soon.
There's a lot of love for
Patrick in this series.
I'm a fan and I look forward
to doing a breakdown.
YouTobia.
I don't agree with your strategy, Evan.
There are tens of channels
with one million subs
and almost none of them have
3,800 videos as you have.
Even PewDiePie, the king of YouTube
has less videos than you,
but almost 55 million subs.
So what?
It's not my strategy.
It's what YouTube wants.
You can win.
First of all, PewDiePie
started at an earlier time,
where what they cared
about most was views.
This is a different algorithm,
but PewDiePie could win even harder
if he produced more content.
Look at PewDiePie's channel recently.
Look at how many times he's complained
about the YouTube algorithm.
He's complaining instead of adjusting,
and so while he still may be number one,
and he still produces content that
his channel and his audience enjoys,
he's fighting the YouTube algorithm,
instead of going with it.
What I'm saying is you could do that,
you could still have success,
it's just not efficient.
If you can produce quality content
and play to the algorithm
that you're dealing with,
you're just going to win harder.
PewDiePie could be winning much harder,
instead of complaining
about the algorithm.
He'd be having a lot more success.
Sure, you don't need to have 3,800 videos.
There's a lot of people that can get there
a lot faster than me,
but if you're producing quality content,
and you're producing it more regularly,
you will win harder, period.
Next up, VCG Construction.
As a new creator do you think going live
could help us get viewers to our channel?
Live is a strange thing.
Live has its own algorithm.
I used to go live all the time.
I used to have five to
eight live things a week.
Usually all on a Thursday.
Condensed back to back.
This is where I had to cut a lot
of the live stuff out of my channel,
because it was a video series
that attracted a lot of
attention immediately.
If you're online and you do live,
people will come and
flood to your channel,
but it was causing
negative subscriber growth.
A lot of people had on
for the live interviews,
they didn't pull as well.
People didn't know who they were.
Maybe they didn't like their advice.
Because of that I lost subscribers.
Not significant.
Not like losing hundreds
of subs each time,
but I don't want to put the effort
into making a video,
and having guests on and booking them,
and then it leading to my
channel getting smaller.
That's a problem.
Unless again, that person
serves a strategic reason.
We have a relationship.
It's leading to something
else outside of business.
I just want to do good by them.
Whatever it is, it's a reason that I know
I'm going to hurt my channel for.
If you do live videos and
they don't do extremely well,
then it's going to hurt your channel.
A lot of people aren't
great at going live,
so I'd really think about it.
I would try it and see,
but again if after three to four episodes,
you're finding that it's not
leading to subscriber growth
and it's hurting your channel.
Then I would cut it, or
work on getting better.
There's a lot of series on my channel that
I could cut, but I want
to work on getting better.
It's part of my growth.
I'm okay holding back the growth
of my channel on some series,
for my own personal development.
There's a strategic reason for doing it.
That's all.
Alexander.
I personally get more value
from your channel, Evan.
Gary's channel has become much more
fancy like an action movie.
It looks like a TV series
about an entrepreneur.
Yours has less drive and motion,
but in terms of practical
info and value, much better.
I know the thumbnail has me against Gary,
or me against Grant.
It's not meant to say that my channel
is any better or worse.
You'll get different things from Gary.
You'll get different things from Grant.
You'll get different things from me.
It's awesome.
We al serve our own niche.
I'm a fan of what Gary does.
I watch pretty much all of his episodes.
I love the support.
The idea here isn't to
bash Gary or bash Grant,
it's to look at what
they're doing on YouTube,
compare it to what I'm
doing, for me to learn,
and also for me to give
you guys lessons for you,
to help you in your growth for YouTube,
but I don't want to get into
whose channel is better.
There's a lot of love for Patrick
Bet-David too in the chat.
I love it,
but I don't want to get into
whose channel is better and why.
That's not the point of this.
I want to help you build your channel,
and build your business.
Next up is ExploreList.
Just stumbled across your channel,
and watched this video with interest.
You've obviously focused your energy
on building a large number of subscribers,
but should it not be on the
number of views you're getting?
I'm not a Gary V. fanboy,
but his videos appear to
be considerably higher,
and I was wondering why you were focusing
on number of subscribers,
compared with getting
more views on your videos.
I've talked about this a little bit,
and again, me versus Gary,
it's not something I
really want to get into,
but our strategies, our
tactics, super interested,
because maybe I can
learn something as well.
Looking at Gary's stuff,
he saw his big growth when he went
from one video a day to two a day.
Even from one or two a week
to once a day to two a day,
that's when he started
seeing the massive growth.
That's why he's catching up,
and going to pass me on
YouTube for subscribers.
If I'm looking at the metrics though,
I don't care about views.
We've talked about this already.
When I'm looking at how
to evaluate a series,
you look at watch time and you
look at subscriptions driven.
The difference between my
content and Gary's content,
a lot of Gary's stuff hits
with fire immediately,
and then fades.
Most of his daily vlog content,
whether you're a fan.
Some people don't like the action motion.
Some people love it,
and they get inspired,
and that's what motivates them
to want to do more work.
Whether you like it or not,
if you're following someone's vlog,
typically it's a rabid fanbase
who watch every episode,
but they don't go back.
Gary V. Episode 30, whatever his vlog was.
Most people aren't going
to be watching that.
You'll see a huge spike.
You gets lots of views,
and then it crashes.
A lot of my videos are geared
for longterm consumption.
The initial views don't
necessarily take off.
My videos are also a lot longer typically,
than what Gary's putting out.
My watch time versus Gary's,
I would put us up against each other.
I'd love to see what Gary's watch time is.
I would say that I get
more watch time than Gary.
I think I get more views than Gary.
Let's check it out.
Let's check it out right now.
Let's go to Social Blade live.
This is a cool tool here.
You have the option to compare.
Modelingthemasters, that's me.
Gary Vaynerchuk.
Let's compare.
Subs, I'm still ahead,
but he's closing the gap.
He's getting there.
I'm red.
He's 20,000 subs behind at the moment.
He's getting there.
Let's see what our subs per day.
Look at that, he's had one
crazy day where he grew.
We're still kind of close,
but he's beating me a little bit.
It's close.
Views.
I don't know what happened there.
We have averages.
I get 189,000 daily views.
He gets 145,000 daily views.
1,100 daily subs.
I'm ahead of Gary on daily views.
That's not surprising.
You're looking at views as a metric,
but you're only looking at short term
immediate views when a video launches,
where a lot of my stuff
takes time to build up.
I build content that I think is
relevant and valuable forever,
and a lot of Gary's stuff is super timely.
It's not right or wrong.
Everybody has their approach,
and Gary as I said has
passed me on subscribers,
but I'm ahead of him on views.
Wesley.
Love this series.
Can't wait for the next month's episode.
Thank you for the love, Wesley.
Hey if there's somebody you want me
to compare my channel to,
and again, the comparison is not
to say who's better than who,
it's to look at what that
other person is doing,
give some recommendations and advice,
and through that process you guys
can learn as well to
help build your channel.
If there's something
you want me to do next,
in the breakdown comparison,
let me know in the comments,
and I might just do it.
Next up, Black Conservative Media.
Thank you for this video.
Does an intro help with your YouTube page?
Also what inspired you to start your page?
Thanks.
This goes against what most people say.
The YouTube experts.
An intro video does very
little for your channel.
I'm not a fan of having intro videos.
I think the best thing that you can do
and you can test it.
Test it, one day against another.
A lot of people put a lot of
effort into making intro video.
First off, most people
don't go to your home page
and watch a video there,
but even the ones that do,
what I want to hit them with,
is the video that will lead to
the most subscriber growth,
and so I think and I've tested,
having a video at the front.
You can go in your analytics
and look at all the videos that you have.
Look at what video leads to
the most subscriber growth.
For me, it's one of my top 10s.
It's between Steve Jobs and Tony Robbins,
or one of the top 10s.
I'll put that video as the
one that I want to put,
because it leads to the
most subscriber growth.
The whole idea of you
need to tell the person,
tell the audience how many
videos you're going to put,
and what your schedule is
like and all this stuff.
People don't care.
I can tell you what my schedule is.
Most people don't care.
Most people don't remember.
Most people don't plan their schedule
according to one YouTuber's schedule.
There may be one that you
just really absolutely love,
and you're a hardcore diehard fan of,
but for the most part people
don't care what your schedule is.
Don't tell them.
Just make awesome stuff
as often as you can,
and the intro video on your channel
should not be a welcome video.
It should be the video
that converts the highest.
If your goal is YouTube subscribers,
the video that is on the
home page of your channel
should be the one that
converts the highest,
and you know what that is by
just looking at your analytics.
I think it's the best way to go.
Next up, Soheil.
Hi, Evan, a thought.
I don't think it's the YouTube algorithm
that has anything to do
with number of subscribers.
Algorithm can directly help your video
to be ranked higher in search,
but only indirectly can help
with number of subscribers,
just by making more people
to watch your videos,
and therefore get
interested in at least one,
and then subscribe.
That is mostly true.
That's what I'm talking about too.
The whole point of the algorithm
is to get your video showing up.
To get your video being
recommended to people.
Your subscribers and non subscribers
so that you get watch time,
so that you get attention,
you get views, you get
comments, you get engagement.
If your video shows up,
you're going to get more subscribers.
That's the YouTube algorithm
that we're talking about.
Now the part that you're missing,
that I haven't really talked
about either on this series,
is there's a thing called view velocity.
When you first put out
a video on your channel.
It's not a live video.
You just launch a video.
How quickly that video gets watch time
is really really really important.
If the video starts getting
watch time really quickly,
YouTube will promote it more.
If it's not getting
watch time very quickly,
then it's going to promote it less.
That's where your subscribers
can really help you,
because if you have a big subscriber base
and they watch a new video
that you put up really quickly,
it'll help the view velocity,
which helps to get
ranked in the algorithm,
which will help new people
find your videos as well.
There you go.
Next up is Nick.
Great video.
I'm taking this message to heart.
I recently launched my
YouTube channel for therapy
and I'm uploading approximately
five videos a week.
I love that.
My goal is to post daily.
As a brand new channel my question is,
how do you deal with not getting views?
Should I not even look at the numbers
and just keep posting
on a consistent basis.
I want to make sure I'm
not missing anything.
Thank you in advance, Nick.
Nick, when you're first starting out,
you can't get super attached to it.
You also don't have enough data
to really make important decisions.
When I'm breaking down Grant's videos,
there's enough data to work with.
He has 200 something thousand subscribers.
He's making consistent content.
He's done a lot of videos in a series.
We can see.
Here's how much an average
Grant video will do.
Here's how much this series is doing.
You can see is it better or worse?
Is it worth continuing the series or not?
If a video has grant
in it, it does better.
If a video doesn't have Grant in it,
it doesn't do as well.
If Grant is allowed to be live and crazy
and do his thing, it does better.
If it's staged and
performed and structured,
it doesn't do as well.
You can start to outline trends
and he has enough data to make a decision.
When you're first getting started,
you don't have enough
data to make a decision.
All I would focus on right now,
is just getting better.
Listen, at the start of a YouTube channel,
you're going to suck anyway.
Your videos aren't going to be great.
You may be a great therapist.
You may know your craft inside out.
That doesn't mean you're great on camera.
That doesn't mean you're
great at making videos.
Doesn't mean your editing is amazing.
I'm sure there's a lot of repetition.
I'm sure there's some
nervousness still coming out.
There's a lot that could be better.
I would focus in the early days,
more on just making better videos.
I'm a firm believer that the
quantity leads to the quality,
and now is the time to experiment,
to try to hone your skills to improve,
and not get so attached to how many views
one video gets or how many
comments one video gets.
At the start of thing,
my channel wasn't getting any comments.
Zero.
The fact that you have one
or two comments coming in
on a video, if that
happens, that's amazing,
but one video may spike
for the wrong reason.
Maybe you put some keyword
in there, and that takes off,
and you think you did a
great job, but you didn't.
Really right now I would not
pay attention to the numbers.
If you're only doing this to get numbers,
then you're in it for the wrong reasons.
Focus on building your
skills, honing your craft,
and get better.
Otherwise the numbers are
going to keep pulling you down.
You look at that everyday,
you're going to be depressed.
Next up is Sue.
I love that you say we have to get better.
We, not the camera, not the lighting.
I could, okay, I will be honest,
I've spent hours researching
lights and so on,
and when I realized that this is
just a nasty way of
resisting moving forward,
because I am just scared.
Sue, that's some amazing self awareness.
Listen, we all want shortcuts.
We all want shortcuts.
The last question, about Nick.
He wants to grow his channel too.
We want shortcuts.
If you think it's easy
to go out and buy lights.
It's easy to spend
whatever it is, $10, $30,
a couple hundred dollars on some lights.
It's easy to think if
I get a better camera
then things will be better,
but the end of the day,
if you're making this kind of video,
a talking head video,
you're an expert.
Sue, I don't know what you're doing.
You're Negotiation Angels.
If you're a negotiator,
and you're making expert quality content.
Look at Grant's stuff.
Grant has budget.
Grant has a team.
There's people behind
those professional cameras.
There's sets.
That he has invested
into building up a set.
There's structure.
He's paying people to do do this with him
and his best stuff is Grant on a phone,
going on a rant or showing something,
or somebody following Grant around,
with a jerky camera while he's
explaining something or doing something.
In a job interview or in a sales cAll.
That's his best stuff,
because Grant has talent.
Grant has skills.
If you have the skills at what you do,
then you can rise to go to the top,
and so it's really important
that you focus on that.
It's hard work.
You have to make a lot of videos.
You've got to practice,
like anything else.
If you're a negotiator, you
didn't just come out of the womb
as a great negotiator.
You had to practice.
You had to improve.
You had to learn.
You had to train.
Apply that same approach.
It's slow, it's frustrating,
it's painful, and it sucks.
I'd love to say buy these $100 lights
and you're set and your videos
will all be amazing forever,
but that's not the shortcut,
and if you understand that
if you work on your craft
and get better at it daily,
and you keep working on it,
your videos will get better.
Udoka.
Please comment on how
someone who works another job
or is running a business can fit a decent
YouTube following into the schedule.
It takes me half a day
to record a short video
and another three hours to edit it.
Even with the simplest edits,
I don't have time to produce videos
to post multiple times per week,
and edit them down and all that.
Is there any help?
Should I even bother,
until I'm able to spend more time on this?
You just practice.
When I made my first videos,
it took me more than a day to make.
Of just me, talking head,
like me with a camera.
That's it, because I made mistakes,
because I was nervous,
because I was scared,
because I sucked and I
wanted to do it again.
I was trying to memorize
this script and I forgot
so I had to take and
take and take and take.
Hundreds of time to do one video,
and now when I get to the studio,
we'll record 60 videos,
70 videos in a day.
The more you practice something,
the better you're going to get.
Depending on what it is that you're doing,
it won't take you half a day,
as you get better at it to film the video.
It may not take you three
hours to edit something
as you get better at it.
Practice, practice, so you
can get that half a day video
down to 30 minutes.
Get better,
and as you build up you
can start to look at,
okay, if I don't want to,
if my best talents are
in front of the camera,
I need to get an editor.
That's what helped me
move from a video a week,
to a video a day, is I got an editor.
You can get part time
people, full time people.
You don't need to go full
time at the start though.
I love Upwork.
It's a website to find
people around the world,
who are talented and who have a passion
for what you're doing,
who want to work from home.
I have two and a half full
time editors on Upwork,
and I send the files by DropBox,
and that's how I do it.
If this is your dream, don't give up.
It's frustrating and it's slow
because you know what
a good video looks like
and you know that your
quantity needs to be better,
but like anything else at
the start of anything else,
expect to suck at the beginning.
If you're going to learn Taekwondo,
you can look at Taekwondo masters
and say these guys are great.
Just because they're great,
doesn't mean that you need to quit.
Just practice.
Get better.
You'll pick up the moves faster,
and then as you grow you
can surround yourself
with a team to help you
pick up the pace even more.
Pearcey111, yeah but Gary has someone else
film and edit all his videos.
This is why he can post
four or more a day.
Also some of his videos are only
one or two minutes long
which are just cuts from
some of the longer videos.
Sure, Gary has an advantage.
I have an advantage.
I have people on my team.
We've got eight people on my YouTube team.
That allows me to post three times a day.
You can't get to three times day
or even once a day right away,
but plan for it.
That's where you need to get to.
That's the standard right now.
That's where you want to be
if you want to win with
the YouTube algorithm.
You're not there yet,
just like anything else.
If you want to get that car,
you want to have those savings,
you want to have this
level of customer growth,
you want to develop this website,
create this product, whatever it is,
you have a goal, work towards it.
You start where you
are with what you have.
That's every successful person's story.
If all you look at is someone
like Gary or me who
has 700,000 subscribers
and think that you can compete
at that level right now,
you're going to be depressed.
You can't compare your start to
somebody else's middle.
Look at how we started, and you'll see.
You'll see the growth.
That's what you need to do for yourself.
The one or two minute clips,
they don't always work.
Look at Grant's channel.
I did a breakdown.
The one or two minute
clips from his channel
are hurting his channel.
He's getting some
subscriber growth from it,
but he's getting not great watch time,
and if he keeps doing it,
it's going to hurt his future
videos that are coming out.
It's not that it's a great strategy to do.
Next up, Professor Nez.
I like your points Evan,
but I actually felt Gary was overkill
when he accelerated his uploads.
I actually unsubscribed to him.
It was overbearing.
Shouldn't there be some kind of balance?
Don't you think quantity
affects the quality
and that your audience will be fatigued
by upload overload?
Thank you.
Professor Nez, I hear you man.
Some people will unsubscribe,
but he's winning.
The data shows otherwise.
For every you who is
saying I don't like that.
I'm not a huge fan of the Daily V series.
I much prefer his Ask Gary V. Show.
I learned a lot more from that.
I don't need to see Gary hustling
for me to want to hustle harder.
I don't get as much education
from the Daily V stuff.
I'm not as big a fan of
that as I am of the show.
I didn't unsubscribe to him and you did,
but he's winning.
People love that stuff.
For every one of you,
there's 10 people who
want more of the stuff.
You have to pay attention to the series.
This entire video that I
broke down Grant's stuff,
it's the same thing.
He's posting a lot of content,
and if he pays attention to the series
and what's doing well and what's not,
and cut out the weak ones
and replace them with better ones,
he's going to win even harder.
I hear you,
but there's always room for quality,
and I think you should
cannibalize yourself first.
Don't let somebody else
take your audience away.
Cannibalize yourself.
If you can produce quality stuff,
go ahead and do it.
Some people you will lose.
Some people will complain.
I'm sure some people
complained on Gary's channel
that he was producing too much.
People have unsubscribed from me,
for producing too much content,
and the stuff I was making
wasn't hitting them enough.
It wasn't good enough.
I didn't provide them enough value,
for them to want to stick around.
Maybe they came for one series
and now that's only a third
of the videos that I put out.
They don't like my other stuff,
and it makes sense they're
going to unsubscribe,
but net, I'm winning.
I'm getting more.
Just pay attention to your data.
Gary's data shows that he's winning.
It's sad to lose someone like you,
but it's worth it.
Carl Simmons.
I'm not sure if you mentioned this before,
and watching the YouTube
series at some point,
but how large is your team?
I have eight people on my team.
A mix of editing, researching.
I've got a guy who comes in and films me.
It doesn't really matter.
How big my team is now.
What gear I use now.
It doesn't matter.
Start with what you have.
You can have.
Think about what you're great at.
If you're looking at building a team,
what are you amazing at?
What is the best thing
that you want to focus
most of your time at,
and then bring people on
who can help support that.
The first hire for me
was a part time editor,
that allowed me to go
from one video a week
to one a day,
but from a part time editor,
because it took me so long editing,
and I didn't want to be an editor.
I had no ambition to get better at it.
I didn't want to learn the skills
to improve myself at it.
I wanted to be in front of the camera.
Hiring an editor helped me improve,
and that let me do one video a day.
It was me and an editor.
It's great context I guess,
to understand where the people are at,
but if you're just comparing yourself,
it's a challenge right,
like I said before.
If you compare your beginning
to somebody else's middle,
you're going to lose.
Next up is Nick.
Great stuff, Evan.
Value, value, value!
In response to Andy's comment,
of animations are amazing,
and also add massive amounts of value,
there are channels like Kurzgesagt
in a nutshell that upload once a month.
They only have 59 videos,
but have over three million subs.
Content like that would
be a great fit for him
if he has the ability and time to compete,
but the rest of us,
we definitely need to upload more.
No, this guy needs to upload more.
Once a month is not enough.
More.
You can do it.
Find a way.
Create more.
Let's compare.
Let's see.
I'm going to share my screen.
Never heard of it.
Kurzgesagt in a nutshell.
Here we go, let's compare.
This guy has four million subscribers.
I have 698.
He's crushing me on the subscribers.
He started later than I did as well.
I'm half his daily subs almost,
and more than half his daily views.
I've got 189,000 daily views.
He's at 329,
and he's got four million
subscribers to my 700,000.
This is what happens when you
don't promote enough content.
He's winning, but he could win harder
if he produced more content.
He's losing the YouTube algorithm game,
and that may not be what he wants to do,
but he's going on the slow streets.
He's riding horse and buggy.
That's what he's doing.
Where I want him to ride
a Ferrari by doing more.
He's fighting against
the YouTube algorithm
and he's winning,
because his content is so good.
I haven't checked it out,
but to get four million subscribers,
you're doing something right,
but he could be winning harder
if he had better strategies.
Do more.
Come on Kurzgesagt.
You got to do more.
You can, and part of that is for me,
I believe if you have the
ability to change the world,
you have the ability to help,
then you have the
responsibility to do as well.
A lot of the people with,
I just came back from Clamber Con.
A lot of these people
with bigger channels,
they're doing okay,
but they could be doing more.
They could be having a bigger impact.
They could be making a bigger reach.
They're not working as hard as they could,
and their stuff means something to people.
If you have the ability
to change the world,
you have the ability to have
an impact on people's lives,
and you have the
responsibility to do more.
This guy's going to
get crushed by somebody
who understands the
YouTube algorithm better
and produces inferior quality content.
That upsets me.
Next up is Leo.
Cheers, Evan.
I learnt a good lesson,
but I must as neither Gary can be you
nor you can be him,
and the game is to beat
yourself at this game.
100%.
Your goal is to be the
best version of you,
but you can learn from other people
to help become the best version of you,
and especially learn
from their strategies.
The fastest way to get somewhere
is to look at who has already gone there
and learn from them.
If you want to have YouTube success,
go look at the people
who've had YouTube success,
and model them to help
you get there faster,
and that's the point of this series.
I'm trying to share with you guys
the strategies that I've used to help me,
as well as learning from other people,
giving advice on what
I would do differently,
or why they're winning so much.
Nikolai, master Evan,
I think one of the reasons
why the livestreams
don't get as much as the replays
are the topics to be covered,
notifications, alerts, reminders,
when the livestream starts,
and probably timing on YouTube's
heavy viewership traffic.
It's a different algorithm.
The reasons why livestreams
don't do as well,
is it's a different algorithm.
What YouTube does is they promote
a livestream really heavily,
when it first comes out.
It'll show up on the right hand side
for the suggested videos, related videos.
It'll send notifications to people
who've signed up to be a
subscriber on your channel.
There's options in the backend
to have it featured when you go live
across all your videos,
and that'll help drive a lot of people
immediately to your video,
but once it's done, once it's finished,
YouTube doesn't promote it as well
as the other videos.
They just don't.
It's a different algorithm.
That's why.
It sucks, because I love doing live stuff,
but unless you have
really really good guests
it's going to hurt your channel.
Relaxing Sleep Station.
What do you think about reducing
the quantity to focus more on
the quality of the videos?
Both.
Do both.
Quantity plus quality.
Quantity leads to the quality.
Doing more quantity improves your skills
to get better for the quality.
At the end of the day it's quality
that's what's going to matter.
If you produce 100 videos a day,
and they're all crap,
nobody's going to watch or subscribe
or comment or share.
You get zero watch time.
You need good stuff,
but more good stuff,
and I want you to win
the YouTube algorithm
and produce more high quality stuff.
Do both, get better, move faster.
Practice, practice, practice.
Young Caesar.
Evan, you're winning.
You approach us calmly and firm
instead of too hyper,
and I come across Gary too hyper.
You're calm and welcoming.
Keep it up.
There's lots of people who love the hyper
and would much rather watch Gary than me.
It's okay.
You got to go all in on you.
Again our styles are
not what's in question.
I'm looking at the tactics
that he's used on his channel
to pull up things that
you could learn from
and maybe me too.
Next up, Sukhum.
Hey, Evan.
My first time ever
commenting on your channel
and I'm loving the message
and value you bring.
That's awesome man.
Welcome aboard.
I actually started vlogging a week ago
and put out content once
a day to a challenge.
The last three days I
posted two videos a day
and I'm seeing more people are
checking out my channel,
and more engagement.
Thanks for the tips and
keep up the great work.
First of all, I love it.
Why I'm shaking my head is,
the amount of people who will look at
and who are commenting,
that this strategy doesn't work,
but then actually don't go out and try it.
Just try it.
Here's a guy whose vlogging
and he goes two a day,
and he's getting more results.
It's not a strategy.
It just works.
It's what YouTube wants right now.
It's their algorithm.
It works so do it,
or if you can't do it,
you know that you're not
playing to the algorithm
and you made that strategic
decision for whatever reason.,
but it's not this is my opinion.
The people who are commenting that
this is your opinion, and it doesn't work,
just try it.
Before saying that something doesn't work,
you have to try it and actually see.
Sukhum, first of all
congrats on the new vlog.
It's awesome, and it's
great that you tried it,
and it's great that you're getting result.
There's a lot more comments,
but I think I'm going to end it there.
That was a lot of Q and A.
More than I expected,
but I had fun doing it.
Guys, thank you so much for watching.
Let me know what questions you have
to help you build your YouTube channel.
You have a question for me,
leave it down in the comments below,
I will try to answer it next time.
I did a lot of Q and A this time,
so hopefully we'll get to more next time.
Remember, you need lots of videos,
the quantity leads to the quality,
but you need lots of quality videos
to win YouTube's algorithm game now,
and pay attention to the series.
Pay attention to which
videos are doing well.
Pay attention to the watch time.
Pay attention to
subscribers gained and lost,
and kill the series
that are not doing well.
Replace them with new ones.
Test, try, and see what works.
That's going to help you
really build your channel up.
Until next month,
remember, I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
I'll see you soon.